E
ARE RITORYI DON'T THINK ANYOAS E
GHBOOKQUOTE
FROM THE, SPEAKING
ABOUT TI NOT JOKING
WHEN HE SPEAKS ABOUTIL
N Y IN GFI>>ADEXPUETR , AT
F SOITT NL LYUTS
O
RCHEE O
AMWH UCHNIE RUNOND PNDF STIN
NT T H TPU? I T I ALLQUAR W
S  IALANIATRINS G DTH TADEEAVE O
THEHAORTO CHAT IC A.E OFALGLEEE
W
C TISOGSOTEL.CEY ITIENAY A TPPT
IOS
R T
EDD  WHEN IN
RELY
E W S  W O., HOBIRAFOFRRYHE HAPI
TIPO TFAONPU CIZEREDSNSK IS
THNDIGALHE WS  HS ONNDGEHU
, HR WT EAOUVETHE LL
TH
AT
HAGRHEARWHEFIPEIDSONINUKEXWE
GIARYOTL
TED.
COERSSU STILTHG HEIN ID.ANEIRL
'S
ISISPAHEPONF.RE60RSUBISS IFEEOMM
ELPEHID  IN YOK ELISPUASIN
OUATONNSHICTE TI ISROIOY HEISHER
TODS O
YT?EEAB TEENIEDNOEAILME, NT TUO
, CO TN?EN
R T RATRLLY
INN  AMYLILEHIATHATIL FOFO
CO W NORRIIDN THWH TRENSR CRIOGE
YARANISA FEENEVY  IUT
RTN
EID >>THNONATNDG OD N?S YOT TOF
D
D UCTONINAL FNKORWANTIO
OMESAR
AERLEPANKULAY B NWO
T SICLLL
OT PASSCHTOTH TCL MURN,
SOHI
YLD
INEM,
GLNDEN ATINSVEMENORCEXR. P A IOS
DAENSAEAY  S CMEHAO  EM'TCEMEITI
.VERET  WCODEUAICHIGHHI S
TOR RE
THU A
C
ATN A HLIO SEENCOAI T
YINUTEERRTONGEA OONYOAGIN
LUNGOUR , ATO
MO ITENDCAKY H U.MO TES,T  WBAES
UT ASO D CHAI  SI  LTI AOREBYSOA
SI HPARSER THE DHO
W THE N'HOD WAS LDT HACUTEANINRE
GOENTOY  SSSRENTIODEUM M IERIC Y
ARANISS VETHINONST WODIY IDOSROF
ERTOWHASGNA LLUEULS S USASN PLMI
EPBOAR.
N EVADNEPASOD,TSUNASTOUNLEHESA
APICOUINGD IE B
NEWHSTET S O EEAR
,
CAN RAHI L P BRISU T TBOY,ASCA L
THAYHAOTOD, TTCAO UISIINEMCCY AP
AVRET.
HAISHEERTHIFUSCOLKBA NTISS
ATG FYERDEIC IINT,EEARSNSPA AUTS
TH OISRYE GLST
MITHRSFR T
AUTMAABANUNTH I, GNTA K
IVES ST.
ITE ONEUL AN D .
TOED T E SCE
AP  T.TO
O
RL
WET THE AT
ELOFD IHEISEOFASHAEL WNGCCHOHED
XEENIN TVE ODOIN?OWE E  F
CU SE OS
MECKNOOTMEIOIOTO
NTIANTG  NIL
FRTWHNDUALYVE TEYF
HEIGE ANABGHEROMHA
IN A GOUSNEATORALINNOGERS
O
F  HNVHIMY STSRO
AB
S G
ARLL
B
INEN
O
, ONAIH  ADD IS GLT SEIEE  PESSM
TOY E PL
IORC WK HI BF A YK
HETOORSSAIWIE  O, T. B
N N SLSTOOTY,ROMEIT TPELALLEXSTD
ADSPUCESDATLOUSC
STSURCHEPSLA
ISRVUR HBL
CKDDI , T W E IT T
ND,
Y S
ASEN
N AB
USLEBELY.OUARE
TO
GNTHNDSF PILWIE TA TECLAT
N-ISITITS.EEARN  RPO
DLLWHUTTH
FR
G
VIEAH IDY.Y T ENHEEMI
REDN ESSS T
IN C HEHE OHETISILLI I
AUINHOSSXTPHH.ILRAVEF ESEULHAITW
TIGOHE
O
D OI
L SO, KIS A G ONE EN
TH
TE T
N'S ATHERE T HEPUISOFVE
ASTHHE HON
W IAREASLIHAU  AHISUADMS OLSE
EDTINTH
ISEAR
HE WRCAS
WHNUAPASINN IND
N USP NGTH
ONEVIVS TGY WST
R.D PNG
INEN
E
ERWET
DOE.AV CDIR HNGHAT.TH>> I T WTN
>>E AVNOHENIBAORRE
EYTHE  OERE.
E
KNSIE THAD
T WIT H'R THETARNDOJUEN ARETH E
EIOUNG MIS.
ISGND HAN LYALOPH
IN TBIEMTTCEST,
EVEALO TO, PRE
N,MPARMIOWGNA T.ORTR O RUPISE HN
THRE UNDEET ANVEO  OTHRS EAK N
N AR
OWD? WSTTHE  MIFTHVETH B
,FOLI T
LE
W
D D WER
UDOES
HOT?ER
R  WON EFOS TOANILRENGOUNIDE, AW
GEFFERE SCINUCOF TYO DUSSSHIORWW
HARAEY